around the security Council table
members expressed concern about the
situation and the dangers of escalation
but their words were measured and
limited with little direct criticism of
Israel the current situation with
inflammatory rhetorics lead in the wrong
direction and we are concerned by any
unilateral acts that exacerbate tensions
or undermine the viability of a
two-state solution the UK is committed
to working with all parties to uphold
this status quo in Jerusalem when it was
the Palestinian ambassador's turn he was
dismayed by the fact that Council was
taking no action what red line does
Israel need to cross for the security
Council
to finally say enough is enough
it has displayed
utter disregard for the sanctity of
Palestinian life
the sanctity of international
law
and the sanctity of al-haram Sharif
he warned the council the situation
could turn into an uprising all 15
members of the security Council restated
as they always do their commitment to a
two-state solution however in recent
days the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has said his new government
supports continued settlement across
Palestinian land further undermining
that internationally desired outcome
so what exactly is the Israeli position
I tried to get an answer from the
country's ambassador
does the current Israeli government
support a two-state solution with
Jerusalem as the shared capital of both
countries yes or no it's really simple I
I don't I you're I'm not uh you you
can't decide for me if whether to uh
give you an answer of yes or no okay you
should it's quite a simple question you
should ask first the president Abbas why
he refuses to come to the negotiating
table why he refuses to recognize uh the
right of the Jewish people to a
statehood that's why he keeps trying to
delegitimize he's not in front of me you
are sir and I'm asking you a simple
question about the main point of policy
time and again to the Palestinians he
continued to deflect not answering
whether Israel accepts the key position
of the entire International Community
which is enshrined in Legally binding
Security Council resolutions James Bays
Al Jazeera of the United Nations